hallo deutsch schule wortschatz büro der
computer der computer
ich arbeite am computer ich arbeite am
computer
der schreibtisch
der schreibtisch der computer steht auf
dem schreibtisch der computer steht auf
dem schreibtisch der bürostuhl der
bürostuhl
ich sitze auf dem bürostuhl
ich sitze auf dem bürostuhl der
bürostuhl hat rollen der bürostuhl hat
rollen
die rollen die rollen die tastatur die
tastatur
ich tippe auf der tastatur
ich tippe auf der tastatur auf der
tastatur sind buchstaben auf der
tastatur sind buchstaben die
computermaus die computermaus
ich benutze die maus am computer
ich klicke mit der maus ich klicke mit
der maus die aktenordner
die aktenordner
die aktenordner ordnen akten die
aktenordner ordnen akten
akten sind wichtige dokumente akten sind
wichtige dokumente
der aktenschrank der aktenschrank
der bleistift der bleistift
ich schreibe mit dem bleistift ich
schreibe mit dem bleistift benutzt du
auch gerne einen bleistift
der füllfederhalter der füllfederhalter
der fülle der füller
ich schreibe mit dem füller ich schreibe
mit dem füller
der kugelschreiber der kugelschreiber
ich schreibe mit dem kugelschreiber
der textmarker der textmarker ich
markiere den text mit dem textmarker ich
markiere den text mit dem textmarker die
schere die scherer die schere ist gelb
die schere ist gelb
die schere schneidet das papier die
schere schneidet das papier abonniere
unseren youtube kanal und gib uns jetzt
ein daumen nach oben
das lineal das lineal das lineal ist aus
holz das lineal ist aus holz das holz
lineal das holz lineal die büroklammer
die büroklammer die büroklammer ordnet
das papier die büroklammer ordnet das
papier die pin nadel die kinnlade
das papier anpinnen das papier anpinnen
ich kenne das papier an die wand ich
kenne das papier an die wand die post it
zettel die post it zettel die post it
zettel kleben an der wand die post it
zettel kleben an der wand der
taschenrechner der taschenrechner auf
dem taschenrechner sind auf dem
taschenrechner sind zahlen
ich rechne mit dem taschenrechner
benutzt du gerne den taschenrechner
[Musik]
die aktentasche die aktentasche in der
aktentasche sind akten in der
aktentasche sind akten der kopierer der
kopierer
der kopierer kopiert papier der kopierer
kopiert papier die kopie die kopie
das whiteboard das whiteboard die
präsentation ist auf dem whiteboard die
schreibtischlampe die schreibtischlampe
die schreibtischlampe steht auf dem
schreibtisch die schreibtischlampe steht
auf dem schreibtisch der notizblock
der notizblock
ich mache notizen auf dem notizblock
ich mache notizen auf dem notizblock der
notizzettel der notizzettel ein zettel
ist ein blatt papier ein zettel ist ein
blatt papier
der kalender der kalender
auf dem kalender stehen die monate auf
dem kalender stehen die monate januar
januar/februar februar
märz märz april april
mai mai
juni juni
juli juli august
august
september september oktober
oktober
no
november
dezember dezember
in welchem monat hast du geburtstag der
kalender steht auf dem schreibtisch der
kalender steht auf dem schreibtisch
der terminplaner der terminplaner
ich plane termine mit dem terminplan
ein termin ist ein treffen
das bürogebäude das bürogebäude das büro
ist in dem bürogebäude das büro ist in
dem bürogebäude
das bürogebäude ist ein gebäude mit
vielen büros das bürogebäude ist ein
gebäude mit vielen büros ein gebäude ist
ein haus ein gebäude ist ein haus der
overhead projektor der overhead
projektor der overhead projektor
projiziert ein bild der overhead
projektor projiziert ein bild
für die präsentation benutze ich den
overhead projektor für die präsentation
benutze ich den overhead projektor der
chef der chef der chef ist der boss der
chef ist der boss
dem chef gehört das unternehmen dem chef
gehört das unternehmen
[Musik]
hast du auch einen chef
die mitarbeiter die mitarbeiter
die mitarbeiter arbeiten im büro
die mitarbeiter warten an der tür die
mitarbeiter warten an der tür
das mitarbeitergespräch das
mitarbeitergespräch der chef spricht mit
dem mitarbeiter in einem
[Musik]
mitarbeitergespräch der chef spricht mit
dem mitarbeiter in einem
mitarbeitergespräch die arbeitskollegen
die arbeitskollegen die arbeitskollegen
arbeiten zusammen im büro die
arbeitskollegen arbeiten zusammen im
büro
die arbeitskollegen machen eine
mittagspause
mittagspause der pausenraum der
pausenraum der pausenraum ist ein raum
für die pause der pausenraum ist ein
raum für die pause wir machen eine pause
im pausenraum wir machen eine pause im
pausenraum
im pausenraum gibt es einen kühlschrank
es gibt sogar eine kaffeemaschine im
pausenraum es gibt sogar eine
kaffeemaschine im pausenraum trinkst du
gerne kaffee der meetingraum der meeting
raum
der meeting raum ist ein raum für das
meeting der meeting raum ist ein raum
für das meeting wir haben ein meeting im
meetingraum wir haben ein meeting im
meetingraum
das meeting das meeting ein meeting ist
ein treffen ein meeting ist ein treffen
ich habe um 13 uhr ein meeting mit
meinem chef
wir sprechen über mein gehalt wir
sprechen über mein gehalt das gehalt das
gehalt
wir führen ein gehaltsgespräch wir
führen ein gehaltsgespräch
das gehaltsgespräch das gehaltsgespräch
ein gespräch über das gehalt ist ein
gehaltsgespräch ein gespräch über das
gehalt ist ein gehaltsgespräch die
[Musik]
gehaltserhöhung die gehaltserhöhung
die erhöhung des gehalts ist die
gehaltserhöhung die erhöhung des gehalts
ist die gehaltserhöhung
juhu ich habe eine gehaltserhöhung
bekommen
bekommen hast du auch schon mal eine
gehaltserhöhung bekommen
abonniere unseren youtube kanal und gib
uns jetzt ein daum nach oben wenn dir
dieses video gefallen hat
und in dieser playlist findest du
weitere lektionen zum deutsch lernen
klicke jetzt auf diese playlist